hi this is presto occur consider a floor
with horizontal lines that are spaced
two units apart you drop a needle of
length one on the floor sometimes when
you drop the needle it'll intersect one
of the horizontal lines but other times
it won't you can imagine repeating this
experiment many times the question for
you is Buffon x' needle problem what is
the probability that a randomly dropped
needle will cross one of the horizontal
lines if you're adventurous give this
problem a try
otherwise keep watching the video I'm
going to present two different proofs of
this problem one way to solve this
problem involves trigonometry and
calculus we're going to consider all the
different ways that this needle of
length one could fall on the floor it
can fall in different vertical positions
but it could also fall at different
angles in this method we're going to
consider all the different vertical
positions and angles and compute the
proportion at which the needle
intersects the horizontal line will
magnify our diagram and we're going to
focus on the middle point of the needle
as a reference this is at 1/2 distance
from one of the ends one of the
variables we'll define is the distance D
which is the distance of the middle part
of the needle to the closest horizontal
line D will be between 0 & 1 this is
because the middle part of the needle
can at most be halfway from one of the
horizontal lines the next variable we'll
define is the angle theta we'll define
this as the acute angle of the needle
relative to the horizontal lines data
will always be between 0 and PI over 2
or 0 and 90 degrees now for a given
distance of the middle part of the
needle to the horizontal line
when will the needle intersect one of
the horizontal lines well it will depend
on the angle that the needle makes you
could think about for a given distance
of the middle part of the needle the
locus of points that the needle could
spin around as an angle
now some of these points the needle will
intersect the horizontal line but some
of them the needle will not so at which
angles will the needle intersect the
horizontal line will use a little bit of
trigonometry we can consider the leg
which is the vertical part of the needle
we know the hypotenuse of the needle is
1/2 because we have half the needle we
can compute this leg of the right
triangle as equaling 1/2 sine of theta
so now when will the needle actually
intersect the horizontal line well this
is when the vertical distance is larger
than the variable D in other word the
needle will cross the horizontal line if
and only if 1/2 sine of theta is greater
than or equal to D well now consider the
space of D and theta and make a graph
the condition that the needle crosses is
the shaded region in this graph so we
can now compute the probability the
needle crosses a horizontal line as
equaling the area under the curve
divided by the area of the entire sample
space which is the rectangle the area
under the curve we can compute using
calculus we'll calculate the integral
from 0 to PI over 2 of 1/2 sine of theta
D theta and that gives us the result of
1/2 the area of the rectangle is the
Eldar part of the equation
while the width is 1/2 and the height is
1 so that means the area of the
rectangle is PI over 2 and that gives us
the probability the needle will
intersect one of the horizontal lines as
1 divided by pi and so this kind of fun
the constant pi appears in this problem
in fact this gives us a numerical way a
practical way that we could actually
approximate pi if you drop the needle on
a floor which has horizontal lines that
were double the size of the needle you
can repeat the experiment n times and
count the number of intersections or
successes X for what we just computed X
divided by n will approach 1 divided by
pi and so the reciprocal if you take the
total number of trials and divide
by the numbers successes that'll give
you an approximation for pi you can give
it a try you might need hundreds or
thousands of tosses to get any sort of
accuracy but it is a physical way that
you could approximate pi so now I'm
going to continue to the second proof
which is Barbieri's proof of Buffon
zeidel we start out with our diagram and
our needle of length 1 but in order to
get to this Bart this proof we're going
to no need to know something about
probability so I'm going to make it a
lot more complicated but this is
actually going to stay with it it's
actually going to get us to our solution
that's going to appear like magic now
for any needle the expected number of
intersections will be 1 times the
probability of having one intersection
plus 2 times the probability of having
two intersections plus three times the
probability of having three
intersections and so on this is the
definition for the expected value of a
discrete random variable so here we have
P of K being the probability that a
needle intersects K times and we're
multiplying it by K now when you have a
needle of length one this acquit this
expression is going to simplify greatly
for a needle length one you can at most
have one intersection the number of
times it can intersect two or three or
so on all of these are going to be equal
to zero there's of course the pedantic
point that you could have the needle
fall exactly horizontally on one of the
lines that would be an infinite number
of intersections but this happens with
measure zero so we can ignore that
extreme possibility if we define e of L
as the expected number of intersections
for a straight needle of length L we've
just figured out that a of one is equal
to P one in other words the expected
number of intersections for straight
needle of length 1 is equal to exactly
the probability you want the probability
that the needle will intersect one of
the horizontal lines but now that we've
used
we made this complicated but now we've
actually reframed the problem in terms
of expectations and if you and this is
where things get interesting so imagine
we subdivide this needle of length 1
in two segments of x and y so you can
think about this as two different
needles of length x and y that have been
joined together what's the total number
of intersections for this needle well by
the linearity of the expectation
operator it's equal to the expected
numbers of just that segment X plus just
this segment Y now these two are not
independent events but nonetheless the
expectation operator is linear and this
is going to give us something
interesting we can actually imagine
needles a different shape imagine a bent
needle that has one line segment X and
another line segment Y this equation is
still going to be true even for bent
needles or needles of different shapes
so now we're going to use if you were
going to create some results about
expectations if you have a needle of
length n the expected number of
intersections of that will be n times
the expected number of intersections of
a needle of length just one in fact we
can generalize this if you have a needle
of length x say a plig '''l needle which
has a perimeter of X the expected number
of intersections will be x times the
expected number of intersections for a
needle of length 1 and to be pedantic
this is where x is a rational number so
now we're going to take all this and now
we're going to drop a very special
needle we'll return to our grid and now
we're going to drop a needle which is a
circle of radius 1 if that needle
happens to fall here it intersects
exactly two times if it drops here you
get one intersection at the top and one
at the bottom and no matter how you drop
this circular needle of radius 1 it's
going to intersect exactly two times now
we're going to relate it to our results
about dropping needles Apple ignant
lengths so imagine we have an inscribed
polygon with n sides and it's
circumscribed polygon events I
I've pictured hexagons but you can
imagine n sided polygons that inscribe
and circumscribed the circle the
expected number of intersections on the
circle can be bounded by the inscribed
and circumscribed polygons and we know
the expected number of intersections for
the circle is always 2 what can we say
about the expected number of
intersections of our polygonal needles
from our results before the expected
number of intersections is related to
the lengths of these polygons so we have
the perimeters of the polygons times the
expected number of intersections for a
needle of length 1 now we do something
interesting we let the number of sides
of these polygons go to infinity as that
happens the inscribed and circumscribed
polygons will converge to the circle
which means that their perimeters are
going to converge to the circumference
of the circle which is equal to 2 pi and
we can substitute in 2 pi for those
perimeters and now we proven that the
expected value of 1 is equal to 2
divided by 2 over pi in other words the
expected number of intersections for
needle length 1 or the probability the
needle intersects one of the lines is
equal to 1 divided by PI and that's the
clever and unique way to figure out who
founds needle problem thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you liked this video
please check out my books they're linked
in the video description